les amboisiens quant à eux retourneront
aux urnes encore plus tôt les 11 et 18
juin prochain pour renouveler l'ensemble
du conseil municipal finalement de liste
se feront face celles du maire sortant
Thierry Boutard et celle de Brice ravier
déjà candidat en 2020 la troisième
candidature celle de Dominique huberdon
a été refusé à cause de justificatifs en
retard de la part de deux colistiers à
moins de 15 jours de ce premier tour
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
deux prétendants au fauteuils de mer
Faustine Luneau
[Musique]
insouciant les touristes sont bien loin
de s'imaginer ce qui se joue à Amboise
la campagne officielle pour l'élection
municipale partielle vient d'être
ouverte avec non pas 3 mais deux
candidats puisque la liste de Dominique
berdon a été rejetée par le tribunal
administratif d'Orléans en cause des
irrégularités concernant les
justificatifs de domicile de deux de ses
colistiers alors quel programme vont
présenter les deux candidats encore en
liste du côté de Thierry Boutard pas de
surprise le maire sortant en temps resté
sur la même ligne qu'en 2020 en
reprenant les projets de son début de
mandat là où il les aura laissés
tel la maison de santé telle l'épicerie
sociale sur les parties plus sanitaires
et sociales mais aussi sur les chantiers
dans la ville nous sommes aussi sur le
schéma de mobilité elle est en pleine
étude sur notre communauté de communes
donc nous sommes vraiment ce que je vous
disais dans la continuité de ce que nous
avons déjà lancé ce qui est prêt à être
engagé ou ce qui est déjà d'ailleurs
engagé quant à son adversaire Brice
ravier prévoit déjà si sa liste est élue
de demander un audit des finances et du
fonctionnement de la collectivité
l'objectif il l'affirme améliorer le
service public il faut redonner la
confiance aux agents réouvrir aussi
le service public l'état civil parce que
c'est aussi une vraie demande des
amboisiens rouvrir des plages faire en
sorte que les amboisiens puissent se
retrouver du service de proximité à des
heures de proximité également voilà ça
c'est vraiment une chose importante pour
moi et puis effectivement et je vous le
disais cette mobilité ce schéma
directeur de mobilité nous le ferons en
priorité
durant ces deux prochaines semaines les
deux candidats tiendront chacun
plusieurs réunions publiques ce sont les
amboisiens qui les départageront le 11
juin
et puis sachez que TV tour en
partenariat avec la NR organisant débat
entre les deux candidats à la mairie
d'Amboise 26 minutes pour permettre aux
habitants de cette commune de voter en
toute connaissance de cause une émission
politique à voir le mardi 6 juin à 19h